if you are registered to vote in the
United States your personal information
has almost definitely just been leaked
it was reported yesterday that the
personal data of a hundred and
ninety-eight million American voters has
been compromised that is roughly how
many people are registered to vote in
the United States the information covers
about 61 percent of the u.s. population
this is almost every voter and this was
the largest known leak of voter records
in history but hold on a second that
Hillary Clinton email server something
something should be more relevant than a
Republican data analytics firm called
deep root analytics leaking this
information and leak is leaked may not
even be the right word here because
basically they were storing all this
data this Republican analytics firm they
were storing all this data of everyone's
voter information on an unsecured server
doesn't exactly sound responsible to me
Pat when it didn't even need to be
hacked it was basically stored there
available to someone who knew what they
were looking for yeah and after the DNC
and the d-triple-c were hacked there was
a lot of people who said that the onus
was really on them that's right because
they didn't do enough to secure their
servers I guess you know this can happen
to any private organization right wing
gwang's included so it would seem and
the information in the database includes
name date of birth home address phone
number ethnicity religion occupation
elections that you voted in information
about who you would be likely to vote
for stances on particular issues maybe
from survey data or elsewhere really
just a ton of information and analytics
everything except for who you voted for
since that is not public information
where do they get this information well
it comes from a range of data sources
everything from donor history during
elections to magazine subscriptions to
other consumer behavior that is
available in databases companies you do
business with sell this information and
to be clear this is not by and large
confidential information it's arguably
sensitive altogether it really paints a
pretty
specific picture of who you are but a
lot of this can be compiled by anybody
if you spend enough time like for
example in New York in North Carolina
there's a website uh where you can
really just look up voter registrations
and that can start to put a picture
together then you can cross-reference
that with addresses and build the
geographical profile you can use social
media and what's publicly available to
build a social profile etc etc and that
is exactly what this Republican
analytics firm deep root did now Alex
laundry who's a co-founder of the
company has put out a statement where he
says in part deep root analytics has
become aware that a large that that a
number of files within our online
storage system were accessed without our
knowledge
since this event has come to our
attention we have updated the access
settings and put protocols in place to
prevent further access well that's great
now that every voter P every every
voters information almost has leaked or
been accessed now they're going to take
it really seriously and aside from the
disturbing nature of a leak like this
many people are probably hearing me talk
about this Pat and didn't even realize
that databases databases like this even
exist but they do Democrats and
Republicans work with data firms and
market researchers and analytics
providers to use big data to target
voters if you find out about this how
could you possibly not be worried about
the attack on net neutrality the recent
Republican bill which will allow your
internet service provider to sell your
browsing history to advertisers
how could anyone even to begin with
think that that's an okay idea but
especially after you learn about the
existence of databases like this how
could you be okay with what Republicans
are opting to allow ISPs to do with our
data right and we've known this for a
long time that if you're registered to
vote that your information is out there
somewhere yes that's why around election
season some people get calls all the
time while other people's don't really
get calls but I think this would be a
goldmine for say private investigators
or advertisers looking to appeal to a
specific audience no doubt about it this
is exactly the type of database
that can be used not only for political
targeting but it can also be used for a
manipulative techniques to sell products
or to influence public opinion and we've
talked about the many ways in which big
data can be can be used to those ends
and this should make us significantly
more concerned about all of what we're
seeing regarding Internet privacy and
Internet freedom and particularly that
Republican law are now allowing your ISP
to sell your browsing history to
advertisers disaster absolute and total
disaster